at the heart
of the entire alex jones defamation
trial
and now the award phase and all of the
viral videos that we've been looking at
at the heart of all of this are the
original claims made by alex jones about
the sandy hook shooting a decade ago
and the central element of those claims
is that at one point alex jones said it
was all fake
it was a false flag orchestrated by
whoever the government them
to create a pretext for the confiscation
of firearms
and a critical moment during this
defamation trial that we've been
watching this week
is when alex jones concedes that the
sandy hook attack was 100 percent real
now
does alex jones actually mean this or is
he saying it because now he has been
pushed into a corner and he believes
this is how you minimize the damages
that he will ultimately
be responsible for well let's take a
listen to the moment where this happened
to the end of 2014
we've had
a video received in evidence
of you stating
your belief at that time
that
no one died at sandy hook that the whole
thing was fake
do you understand as you sit here today
how crazy that is
i have said before that
there's been so many lies and so many
things in the past and i was under a lot
of pressure and i truly when i said
those statements
when i say something i mean it
that i really could believe that it was
totally staged that point and i was
basing that off of
really steve pacinic who is
has been a very prestigious person
do you understand even in getting to
saying that he now recognizes it was
real he's still defending why he thought
it was fake now that it was
absolutely irresponsible of you to do
that it was especially since i met the
parents and
well it's it's 100 real as i said on the
radio yesterday
and as i said here yesterday
it's 100 real
and the media still ran with
lies that i was saying it wasn't real on
air yesterday it's incredible they won't
let me take it back they just want to
keep me in the position of being the
sandy hook man my son got confronted
yesterday objection speculation is what
the media wants mr jones is just saying
all right so now he goes off topic and
it's interrupted now do we believe alex
jones actually believes this now or is
this just a setup for some future
infowars exclusive about how the deep
state and the bilderbergs and the
dracula family forced alex jones to
apologize
or is it going to be well the attack was
real but everything leading up to it and
everything afterwards it's all part of
some larger conspiracy i don't know
i don't know i'm not sure
whether
he is genuinely
sorry for what he did and he believes
that it was wrong
empirically wrong
or that he's just upset that he's now
being held accountable i don't know the
answer to that but i'm curious to hear
from you